الجيش بتاعنا راح فين السؤال ده كان على
لسان كل اسرائيل يوم 7 اكتوبر اللي فات
لما كتائب عز الدين القسام شنت هجومها
الكاسح على مستوطنات غلاف غزه وحققت اللي
كلنا شفناه يومها المحتلين جالهم ديجافو
وبداوا مباشره يفتكروا ايام الرعب اللي
كانت في حرب اكتوبر
1973 وقتها برض جيشهم كان ك سبع نومه ولما
الاسرائيليين بداوا يفوقوا ويشوفوا الجيش
بتاعهم حصل فيه ايه لقوا كوارث مئات
الدبابات المدمره والاف الجنود المقتولين
والمصابين وقرابه 300 اسير والاف المعدات
المنسوفة دي في المعدات والافراد ما كانتش
ماشيه خالص مع السمعه اللي خدوها بعد
النكسه بانهم جيش لا يقهر ولو بصينا
هنلاقي ان سلاح الجو في جيش الاحتلال هو
اهم سلاح عندهم لانه ببساطه بيسمح لهم
بممارسه الشيء اللي بيحبوه دايما
الاستهداف من بعيد لبعيد فالمره دي الحرب
حطت سلاحهم المفضل في مواجهه مباشره مع
حاجه سماها المصريين الحائط الناري
منظومات دفاع جوي من صواريخ سام س انتشرت
على طول القناه وعملت حائط صد من الصواريخ
اللي ساعتها امتلكت قدره ضخمه على تتبع
اسقاط الطائرات الاسرائيليه
فالاسيكلوفير
مش هينفع ندخل في حرب زي دياني احنا
محتاجين طريق مختلف خالص نمشي فيه ونبني
من خلاله الجيش اللي اتبهدل ده بس بشكل
مبتكر فعلشان كده الحل كان بناء جيش متقدم
جدا تكنولوجيا بحيث يجنبهم عناء المواجهات
المباشره لاخر لحظه دي كانت بدايه التطور
الحقيقي للمجمع الصناعي العسكري
الاسرائيلي اللي عدد لا باس بهم الخبراء
العسكريين بيوصفو بانه معجزه تاريخيه في
عالم صناعه الاسلحه ورغم مشاعرنا الكارهه
للكيان المحتل واصطفاف ن مع اهلنا في
فلسطين بس للاسف الخبراء دول عندهم حق
الكيان المحتل يا اخوانا هو واحد من اكثر
الدول متقدمه على مستوى التقنيات العسكريه
وصناعه الاسلحه والاسلحه الاسرائيليه
مشهوره في جميع انحاء العالم فواحده من
الحاجات اللي انا شايفها مهمه جدا هي اننا
لازم نعرف قدراتهم ونذاكر كويس زي ما
المقاومه بتعمل يعني ازاي بنوا صنعتهم
العسكريه المتطوره دي وازاي ممكن نستفيد
من التجربه بتاعتهم لو حابين نصنع اسلحه
محليه وايه مصير الجيش المتطور ده في
عمليه الغزو البري اللي مصرين عليها لقطاع
غزه دي الاسئله اللي هنح نحول نجاوب عليها
مع بعض في حلقه النهارده بس عاوز انبهكم
قبلها لحاجتين مهمين جدا اولا الحلقه دي
زي الحلقه اللي فاتت كل ارباحها برده
هتروح لاهلنا في غزه ان شاء الله دي اقل
حاجه ممكن نعملها ليهم وهنعرف الجهه وهن
اوريكم وصله تبرع بعد ايام زي ما عملنا
قبل كده وتاني حاجه ان المواقع ومنصات
التواصل الاجتماعي عامله قيود كبيره على
انتشار المحتوى المضاد للكيان المحتل زي
ما كلكم شايفين اكيد فهمتكم معانا اللايك
والشير والتفاعل مع الفيديو عشان يظهر
للناس ويزود مبلغ التبرع باذن الله انا
اشرف ابراهيم ده المخبل
[موسيقى]
الاقتصادي قبل ما نبدا انا شخصيا وجميع
فريق المخبر الاقتصادي واعتقد كل واحد من
حضراتكم برض هيكون حابب يشكر شركه كونفرت
ان اللي بعتت لنا علشان يرعوا الحلقه دي
ودفعوا اضعاف المبلغ اللي بيدفع في رعايه
الحلقه علشان يروح لدعم اهلنا في قطاع غزه
من خلال مؤسسه مرساله المصريه شركه كونفرت
ان هي منصه مصريه لاتمت الاعلانات
والتسويق للشركات بمعنى انها بتساعدك تعمل
تسويق واعلانات لشركتك او موقعك على منصات
التواصل الاجتماعي ومحركات البحث باستخدام
الذكاء الاصطناعي زي ما قلت مبلغ الرعايه
كله راح لمؤسسه مرسال اللي بعتت وبتبعت
مواد اغاثه من ادويه وغذاء لاهلنا في قطاع
غزه وحابب برده اشكر كل الشركات اللي بعتت
لنا علشان ترعى الحلقه دي ولكن احنا اخدنا
اكبر مبلغ اتعرض علشان زياده الاستفاده
هتلاقوا بيانات مؤسسه مرسال للي حابب
يتابع الانشطه اللي بيقوموا بها حاليا
لدعم اخواتنا في فلسطين والنشاط الخيري
بتاعهم بشكل عام من اكثر من 100 سنه ومع
بدايه توطين بريطانيا لليهود في فلسطين
كان اليهود بيسكن في شيء اسمه كيبوتس
اراضي زراعيه فلسطينيه بنوا عليها
مستوطنات وطبعا التوطين ده خلى في صراعات
كبيره على الاراضي اللي بتتسرق دي وهنا
هتظهر لنا في الصوره ميليشيات الهجانه
الصهيون
المنظمه العسكريه اللي تاسست سنه
1921 بعد الثوره العربيه واللي بقت مسؤوله
عن الدفاع عن المحتلين واللي هي اساس
الجيش الاسرائيلي الحالي هنط نطه واسعه
لحد اول الثلاثينات لما بدات الهجانه في
بناء ورش لانتاج الالغام والقنابل اليدويه
والمسدسات واتحولت لجيش نظامي عنده مهمتين
بس المهمه الاولى الاستيلاء على اراضي
فلسطينيه اكبر بمساعده وتدريب البريطان
والمهمه الثانيه حمايه المستوطنين
والمهاجرين الجدد بعد انتهاء الحرب
العالميه الثانيه كان واضح ان الجيش
البريطاني هيسيب المنطقه وان الحرب مع
العرب جايه جايه علشان كده اليهود كانوا
مصرين على تسليح نفسهم بشكل اسرع ورغم
انهم استولوا على عدد معتبر من رشاشات
ستين البريطانيه وبداوا ينتجوا نسخ منها
لكن فضلت قدامهم مشكله الذخيره هنا هنوصل
للفكره المبتكره جدا وقتها اللي نفذها
اليهود واللي كانت بدايه المجمع الصناعي
العسكري الاسرائيلي اول ورشه عمل تحت
الارض لانتاج الذخيره من غير القوات
البريطانيه ما تحس صاحب الفكره دي كان
يوسف افيدار رئيس الهجانه ومهاجر يهودي
اوكراني جه في يوم وقال اعضاء الهجانه
الرئيسيين يا جماعه هنبني كيبوتس مزيف
قالوا له ازاي يعني قال لهم هنبني كيبوتس
كامل عباره عن مزرعه وحضانه اطفال ومخبز
لكن الشغل الحقيقي كله هيحصل تحت الارض
هيكون عندنا مصنع كامل بحجم ملعب تنس
بيشتغل فيه من 40 ل 45 شخص وبيص نعوا
ذخيره وطلقات للاسلحه بتاعتنا في مواجهه
الفلسطينيين وبالفعل هربوا معدات تصنيع
الزخيره من بولندا وخلال الفتره ما بين
و148 انتج المصنع السري اللي تحت الارض ده
2.2 مليون طلقه زخيره متخيلين الرقم يا
اخوانا وكانت الذخيره دي بتنتقل في شاحنات
توزيع الحليب المحليه وبتتسبح
بطول وعرض الاراضي الفلسطينيه وفي الفتره
دي برض انتشرت الفكره واتبنى مصانع سريه
كتير بطول وعرض فلسطين سنه
1948 البريطانيين لموا بعض وسابوا فلسطين
واتسس الكيان المحتل ما بقاش في اي مبرر
ان المصانع دي تفضل مستخبيه تحت الارض
بالعكس كان لازم تطلع وفي نفس الوقت يزيد
انتاجها خاصه مع بدء الحرب الاولى بين
العرب واليهود ولان الكيان بدا يتعامل
كدوله وكان عاوز يرسخ الفكره دي كان الحل
علشان يوسعوا انتاج الاسلحه هو انهم
يعززوا القطاع ده عن طريق دمج المصانع في
منظومه الصناعات العسكريه الاسرائيليه
المملوكه للدوله والمعروفه اختصارا بالاي
ام اي واللي كانت تابعه لوزاره الدفاع
الاسرائيليه اللي لسه معموله المهم مع
توافد اليهود من كل انحاء العالم على
الاراضي المحتله كان ضمنهم عدد كبير من
المواهب العلميه اللي تقدر تصمم وتهد
اسلحه مختلفه وكان فيهم واحد اسمه اوزيل
جا المهاجر اليهودي اللي وصل من المانيا
وخرج للنور اشهر مدفع رشاش في العالم
وقتها اللي هو مدفع عوزي او اوزي بالعبريه
المدفع ده رغم انه كان ثقيل وبيعاند دقه
في اصابه الاهداف اللي ابعد من 100 متر
الا انه تسبب في ضجه حقيقيه في كل انحاء
العالم وجاله زباين ومشترين من كل حته من
اليابان والمانيا وبلجيكا وبيرو والبرازيل
والولايات المتحده نفسها وبقى السلاح
المفضل للعصابات الكبرى كمان والسبب انه
كان بسيط ورخيص وينفع للانتاج بالجمله
وبسرعه والاهم انه مناسب جدا للقتال في
البيئات الصعبه وبيستحمل وبعدها تمت دعوه
اوزيل للانضمام الى الفيلق العلمي لجيش
الاحتلال اللي كان بيطور من الصناعات
العسكريه المحليه بعد شويه ظهر للنور
مهاجر يهودي ثاني امريكي المولد اسمه
ادولف ويليام اليش ويمر وده دوره كان اهم
بكتير من اوزيل ادولف يا اخواننا كان شغال
مهندس في شركه لوكد مارتن الامريكيه
للصناعات الدفاعيه اثناء الحرب العالميه
الثانيه وبعد ما خلصت الحرب ساعد في تهريب
طائرات لدوله الاحتلال الناشئه وتجنيد
طيارين يهود علشان يكونوا نواه لسلاح الجو
بتاعهم لكن الاهم انه من مؤسسين الرئيسيين
لشركه صناعات الفضاء الاسرائيليه اي اي اي
احدى اهم شركات الصناعات العسكريه لدوله
الاحتلال حاليه زي ما احنا شايفين كده رغم
ان كل الهمه دي في تكوين صناعه عسكريه
محليه قويه ل ان الكيان الزفر ده كان
مستهلك شار للسلاح الغربي وتحديدا فرنسا
اللي كانت مصدر الاسلحه الاول لاسرائيل
لحد نكسه
1967 في الخمسينات واوائل الستينات كان في
نقاش مهم جدا في الاوساط السياسيه
والعسكريه اللي كان المحتل حوالين
الاستثمار في صناعه وتطوير المعدات
العسكريه والاسلحه وقتها كان في فريقين
فريق من الجنرالات الاسرائيليين المخضرمين
اللي شايفين انه حوالينا اعداء كتير وما
عندناش وقت نبني صناعه اسلحه محليه مستقله
وواسعه ما دام قادرين نجيب اسلحه احسن
وارخص من حلفائنا وفريق ثاني لقى انه
الافضل يستثمروا في بناء مجمع صناعي عسكري
حديث وهو موضوع محتاج وقت طويل وموارد
ضخمه جدا لكن نتيجته احسن بكتير من
الاعتماد على دول ممكن تقفل حنفيه الاسلحه
عليهم في اي لحظه ورغم ان فريق الجنرالات
المخضرم فرض رؤيته واستمر الكيان المحتل
في شراء السلاح بمختلف في الاشكال من
حلفاءه الغربيين الا ان دوله الاحتلال ما
اهملت الصناعه العسكريه المحليه وسعتها
لكن بشكل مش كبير لحد ما وصلنا لسنه
1967 اللي اتحقق فيها سيناريو قفل حنفيه
الاسلحه وقبل النكسه باسبوع تقريبا جت
فرنسا المورد الرئيسي للاسلحه وقتها لدوله
الاحتلال وفرضت حظر على توريد الاسلحه
للمنطقه كلها وقتها فرنسا كانت لسه خارجه
من كام سنه من احتلال طويل للجزائر وكانت
عاوزه تاخد اتجاه سياسي مراعي للقوميه
العربيه من غير ما تثير غضب اسرائيل بشكل
مباشر وواضح بعد الحظر تحول موضوع بناء
صناعه عسكريه اسرائيليه متطوره وشامله
لمساله حياه او موت وفي اول ثلاث سنين من
الحظر الفرنسي ورغم ان الولايات المتحده
تدخلت على طول وبدات تاخد مكانه فرنسا
كمورد الاسلحه الاول لدوله الاحتلال الا
ان تاثير الحظر الفرنسي كان صعب على
الاسرائيليين علشان كده سخروا كل
امكانياتهم وانفقوا بشكل واسع جدا على
تطوير صناعاتهم المحليه ورغم حرب اكتوبر
1973 والخساير العنيفه اللي تكبدها الجيش
الاسرائيلي الا انه واصل تطوير مجمعه
الصناعي العسكري في السبعينات لحد ما
وصلنا للذروه في اوائل الثمانينات واللي
هنلاقي فيها ان نص سكان الكيان المحتل
تقريبا كانوا بيشتغلوا في الصناعات
الدفاعيه وشركات تصنيع الاسلحه
الاسرائيليه نتيجه تطور مجمع الصناعي
العسكري للاحتلال وشركاته مثلا هنلاقيه
ظهر بوضوح تام في حرب سهل البقاع سنه
1982 اللي هي واحده من اكبر المعارك
الجويه في التاريخ الحديث ودي الحرب اللي
شن فيها جيش الاحتلال هجوم جوي كاسح على
سلاح الجو السوري الحرب دي كانت في اتجاه
واحد هو اتجاه سلاح جو الاحتلال اللي نجح
في تدمير 90 طياره مقاتله سوريه بدون ما
يخسر طياره واحده ونجح في تدمير اغلب بطار
الدفاع الجوي السوري في اواخر السبعينات
واوائل الثمانينات وبعد التعافي الاقتصادي
والعسكري لدوله الاحتلال من تابعات حرب
اكتوبر بمساعده امريكا طبعا هنلاقي ان
نشاط انتاج الاسلحه في اسرائيل عموما
استحوذ على حصه كبيره جدا من اجمال النشاط
الصناعي وصلت نسبه الاستثمار في قطاع
الدفاع تحديدا 50% من اجمال الاستثمار
الصناعي في الكيان المحتل كله ولو بصينا
هنلاقي ان ربع القوى العامله الاسرائيليه
الصناعيه كانت شغاله في مشاريع الدفاعيه
ولها علاقه بجيش الاحتلال ده غير ان ربع
ايرادات الصادرات الصناعيه الاسرائيليه
باستثناء الماس كانت جايه من قطاع الدفاع
وثمانيه من اكبر 20 شركه في اسرائيل كانوا
شركات عسكريه او بتعتمد على التعاقدات
العسكريه في انتاج السلع والخدمات لقطاع
الدفاع دايما يا اخوانا هنلاقي ان الانفاق
العسكري الاسرائيلي كان بياثر على التنميه
الاقتصاديه لدوله الاحتلال وكان بيتطلب من
الاسرائيليين طول الوقت انهم يضحوا بجزء
من الرفاه اللي ممكن دوله الاحتلال توفرها
لهم مقابل زياده الانفاق الدفاعي ده ولان
الكيان هو كانان هش وامني في المقام الاول
فدايما كان بيتم تسويء الانفاق العسكري من
قبل السياسيين الاسرائيليين على انه امن
قومي ما ينفعش حد يلعب عنده الاستنتاج ده
وصل له الباحثين الكس منس من جامعه تكساس
اي ان ام ومايكل وارد من جامعه كولورادو
اللي عملوا دراسه في اواخر الثمانينات
اثبتوا فيها ان الميزان يه العسكريه
الاسرائيليه بتستخدم بجانب وظيفتها كاداه
سياسيه اقتصاديه للمساعده في اداره
الاقتصاد الاسرائيلي اللي هو اقتصاد امني
وبتساعد في توفير مناخ انتخابي مناسب
لشغيل المناصب السياسيه في حكومات
الاحتلال والبلاد الشبيهه لو ركزنا مع
مكونات دوله الاحتلال هنلاقي دايما ان
زياده الانفاق الدفاعي المستمره من نشاه
الكيان لحد اللحظه هي نتيجه لشويه عوامل
بديه تماما وبتخلي المجتمع ده مجتمع امني
بامتياز زي انهم مثلا دايما حاسين بالخطر
وكعاده اي مجتمع عسكري
فالاسيكلوفير
النمو الاقتصادي وتقليل نسب البطاله
وبيحاولوا من خلاله خلق وهم انه الاقتصاد
مزدهر قدام الناخبين خاصه المتطرفين منهم
علشان كده اليكس ومايكل توصلوا في نهايه
دراستهم لان المؤسسه العسكريه الاسرائيليه
هي الاليه الماليه الاهم لاي حكومه هناك
لتحفيز الاقتصاد والتاثير على اي انتخابات
وما فيش حكومه ببساطه هتقدر تتغاضى عن
اهميتها السياسيه والاقتصاديه فمع الانفاق
الدفاعي الهائل ده على مر السنين تطورت
الصناعه العسكريه الاسرائيليه جدا وبقى
الكيان المحتل يقدر يصنع كل انواع الاسلحه
في منتصف الثمانينات ادت الازمه
الاقتصاديه اللي ضربت اسرائيل بدءا من سنه
1985 الى ان دوله الاحتلال تاخد اجراءات
قاسيه شويه فيما يخص القطاع الدفاعي وفي
غضون ال 10 سنين التاليه اضطروا لخفض
الانفاق الدفاعي من 13% ل 88% من ناتج
المحلي الاجمالي وده ادى لانخفاض نسبه
شراء جيش الاحتلال لاسلحه من الشركات
الاسرائيليه ل 50% وانخفض عدد موظفي صناعه
الدفاع بنسبه 35% ده ادى لان الاسرائيليين
قعدوا يفكروا في هيكله المجمع الصناعي
العسكري بالكامل وهنا هيظهر للنور برنامج
تلبيوت البرنامج الاهم تقريبا في الجيش
الاسرائيلي بعد حرب اكتوبر في استاذين في
الجامعه العبريه بالقدس ههم شاعول يزيف
وفيليكس دوثان فكروا ان اللي بيحصل في
الجيش الاسرائيلي ده غلط وطريقه تطويره
لاسلحه ونظمه مش سليمه وبداوا يقودوا حمله
لاقناع قاده الجيش بابتكار طريقه افضل
تخليهم يختاروا امهر واسكى الكفاءات
ويبنوا عن طريقها اسلحه ونظم عسكريه جديده
علشان كده خرجوا بفكره برنامج تلبيوت اللي
هو برنامج خاص جدا بيشار لاعضاءه داخل جيش
الاحتلال على انهم اهم مجندين في الجيش
ومهمتهم الاساسيه مش انهم يقاتلوا وانما
يتعلموا يفكروا ويحللوا ويخطط قبل اي شيء
ومجندي الوحده لازم يقضوا 10 سنين على
الاقل في الجيش وده مقارنه بال 32 شهر
اللي بيقضيها من الذكور حاليا والسنتين
للنساء لكن هل معنى ده انهم مش بيقلوا
اكيد لا بالعكس بعد عدد كبير من المقابلات
والاختبارات وبعد ما بيتم قبول عدد محدود
في البرنامج بيزور مجندي الوحده عشرات
الوحدات في القوات البريه والجويه
والبحريه لجيش الاحتلال علشان ياخدوا خبره
في كل سلاح تقريبه وخريجي وحده تلبيت
معظمهم بيكونوا من قوات النخبه ومن قاده
السفن الحربيه والطائرات المقاتله بمختلف
انواعها وفرق القوات البريه وغيرها وبعض
خريج الوحده ما اكتفو بالتفوق العسكري بس
وان نجحوا في تاسيس عشرات من الشركات
الناجحه زي شركه شيك بوينت سوفت وير
تكنولوجيس اللي اسسها ماريو سنخت احد
مجندي الوحده واللي بقت حاليا شركه بقيمه
سوقيه تقترب من 16 مليار دولار وزي شركه
الهارد وير انويت واللي شارك في تاسيسها
اريل ماسوس مجند تاني في الوحده واشتريتها
شركه ابل في 2011 بحوالي 400 مليون دولار
كل الخطوات دي سهمت في ان دوله الاحتلال
تمتلك مجمع صناعي عسكري قوي جدا في صناع
سعات عسكريه متطوره والنتيجه دي انعكست
على الصدرات العسكريه الاسرائيليه اللي
ارتفع حجمها بين عامي 2012 و2022 بنسبه
67% الى رقم قياسي وصل ل 12.5 مليار دولار
امريكي وحاليا الصناعه العسكريه
الاسرائيليه بتمثل
2.4% من سوق الاسلحه العالمي ولو بصينا
على اكبر 50 شركه صناعات دفاعيه في العالم
في 2023 هنلاقي ثلاث شركات اسرائيليه هم
رافائيل واي اي اي وقلبت سيستمز لكن مش
عاوزين ننسى في خضم ده كله ان الامريكيين
برض لعبوا دور رئيسي وحيوي في تطوير
الصناعات الدفاعيه الاسرائيليه من خلال
التمويل وتزويد الاسرائيليين باحدث تقنيات
والدخول المستمر في برامج تسليح مشتركه مع
الشركات الاسرائيليه فالسؤال هنا بقى
المقاومه الفلسطينيه هتعمل ايه مع الجيش
ده كله اللي عنده اسلحه شديده التطور
وحدات نخبه خاصه فريده من نوعها ومجمع
صناعي عسكري شامل متطور جدا وفوق ده كله
دعم امريكي عسكري وتقني لا ينتهي هل الجيش
ده بيتهز طبعا جواب السؤال الثاني معروف
هو بالفعل اتهزم اكث من مره من سينا لحد
غزه مرورا بلبنان في 2006 لكن اجابه
السؤال الاول الاهم هي ان المقاومه
الفلسطينيه بتعرف تعمل كتير جدا مع الجيش
ده وانه مش بالقوه الهائله اللي
الاسرائيليين بيحبوا يصوروه بيها لينا رغم
انه قوي فعلا بشكل
المفارقه المدهشه هنا بجانب نجاحات
المقاومه الفلسطينيه في العشر سنين
الاخيره في ضرب اسطوره الجيش الذي لا يقهر
في مقتل باقل الامكانيات انها بتعيد
تقريبا نفس خطوات تكوين المجمع الصناعي
العسكري الاسرائيلي بس المره دي هو مجمع
صناعي عسكري فلسطيني الكلام ده اللي قد
يبدو مبالغه هو مش مبالغه ابدا يعني لو
بصينا هنلاقي ان المقاومه طورت من
2014 قدرات تصنيع محليه ممتازه للصواريخ
بتاعتها سهمت في رفع عددها من كام ال
صاروخ لحوالي 15000 صاروخ ودي تقديرات
الاستخبارات الاسرائيليه يعني غالبا العدد
اكبر وبالاضافه لده فهم طوروا برنامج
طائرات بدون طيار بيتقدم سنه عن سنه وفي
عمليه طوفان الاقصى الاخيره استخدموا
طياره مسيره لتدمير دبابه مركاه فخر
اسرائيل زي ما بيسموها هناك بقذيفه بسيطه
والمقاومه اعلنت في هجومها القوي
والمباغتة
هو نظام متبر واحد ده غير تصنيعها للزوارق
السريعه المسلحه وغيرها من الاسلحه فزي ما
بدا المجمع الصناعي العسكري لدوله
الاحتلال من تحت ارض كيبوتس في الاراضي
المحتله في اربعينيات القرن العشرين يبدو
ان المقاومه بقى لها اكثر من 10 سنين
واخده نفس المسار بصبر واتقان على الجانب
الاخر هنلاقي ان الاسرائيليين يبدو انهم
استثمروا في التكنولوجيا اكثر من لازم
علشان كده يعقوب اميدرون مستشار الامن
القومي الاسبق لرئيس الوزراء بنيامين
نتنياهو قال بعد عمليه طوفان الاقصى ان
اللي حصل كان اختيار الجيش الاسرائيلي
للاستثمار بشده في التكنولوجيا وده سحب
ميزانيات من اسلحه وقطاعات عسكريه تقليديه
ثانيه على سبيل المثال للحصر لو رجعنا ل
2015 هنلاقي ان جيش الاحتلال بدا يشتغل
على خطه قللت عدد القوات القتاليه
النظاميه وقوات الاحتياط وبسبب ده انخفض
عدد ضباط الصف مثلا بنسبه 10% ل 40,000
وتم تقصير مده الخدمه العسكريه للذكور
اربع شهور علشان تبقى اقل من ثلاث سنين
وبجانب ده تم استنزاف جزء كبير من قوات
الجيش النظاميه في الضفه الغربيه للسيطره
على الفلسطينيين هناك وحمايه المستوطنين
وحمايه المشاريع الجديده برده ودي مهمات
زي ما انتم شايفين مش بتاعه اي جيش نظامي
في مقابل ده رفع من ميزانيات الاستخبارات
وانظمه الرصد والاستشعار واساطير طائرات
المراقبه بدون طيار وانظمه الدفاع الجوي
ومستشاره الانفاق وغيرها استثمر بكثافه
شديده في تكنولوجيا الرصد والتحليل عموما
واللي كلنا شفنا فشلت ازاي في توقع الهجوم
الكاسح للمقاومه مش عاوز اطول على حضراتكم
اكتر من كده لكن يبدو ان النضوج الفلسطيني
على كل المستويات هيؤه لنتائج مختلفه عن
كل مره بيستخدم فيها الاحتلال القوى
الغاشمه مع اهلنا اللي دعواتنا كلها معاهم
وقبل ما اختم حابب اسالكم سؤال مهم في
رايكم تفتكروا في دوله عربيه ممكن تكرر
تجربه صناعه المجمع الصناعي العسكري
الاسرائيلي وايه هي هتابع كل اجاباتكم في
التعليقات وفي النهايه نتمنى السلامه
لاهلنا واخواتنا في قطاع غزه وفي كامل
الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله احنا معاكم
وجنبكم بفكركم بالتفاعل مع الفيديو علشان
يظهر للناس ويفلت من القيود الحاليه
لمنصات التواصل الاجتماعي كلها على اي
محتوى مناهض للكيان المحتل
[موسيقى]
سلام
ا